Overdoses, suicidal
people, domestic violence.
What does the public
have a right to hear?
Where is the line
between public information
and an invasion of privacy
when it comes to police scanners?
For decades, police departments
have communicated through public radio
to dispatch their officers,
attracting a relatively small number
of listeners.
Technology has made it much easier.
In 2012, with the launch of Broadcast Ify
the largest platform
for streaming live audio,
the company currently offers
more than 7600
live audio feeds in different cities
across the country
for police, for fire,
EMS aircraft,
marine and amateur radio communications.
Broadcast
Ify makes their feeds easy
to access through its website
and smartphone apps,
reaching
50 to 60000 listeners
on a typical weekday evening.
Ultimately, the platform offers
the public transparency
to what's going on
in their own backyards.
But is there a cost?
Major cities,
including Denver, San Francisco,
San Diego, Baltimore, Chicago, New York
and Sioux Falls
are now encrypting
their emergency public radio channels
due to concerns of oversharing details
about private civilians
with a much wider
audience publicizing
names and addresses and phone numbers.
It worries some in public safety.
Encrypting radio channels
from the public
would mean that only authorized
emergency professionals
could access this information
about an urgent matter in real time.
We found several examples.
For example,
this an elderly man in Wisconsin
who was in distress.
For a 70 year old male that
fell in the kitchen, unable to get up.
Of course, one could argue
that police scanners help
the public identify individuals
that might be a danger to themselves
or to others.
Even violent, possibly mental
elderly black male subjects.
I think he's walking with a stick or cane
is going to be in front of the store
for an all black clothing.
But at what point does a radio channel
that's meant to uphold public safety
infringe on the private details
of someone's, say, mental health?
If he says
he feels like committing suicide,
the final thoughts
and feelings fight with
her husband cheating on her.
Apart from the privacy
considerations, might the widespread
broadcasting of personal details
cause hesitance
in someone who needs help
before dialing 911?
Joining me
now is the founder of broadcast
to Fi Blanton.
He's also the founder
and CEO of radio reference.
Lindsay, thank you for being here.
This used to be a niche hobby
on my street lived.
The fire chief
Chief Hall Chief
Karl Hall, wonderful guy.
Like they were the only ones
that I remember as having a scanner.
But now
lots of folks have access,
including through your website.
What changed?
Well, obviously,
the Internet and streaming
changed the hobby that, you know,
we grew up with almost 50 years ago,
listening in to our local public
safety agencies
to bring it online,
just like all streaming services.
So that's really
what's changed
in the hobby
for those that listen
to police scanners today.
Can we make it clear that
there's already some level of information
that is not accessible, not shared,
a SWAT team.
And by the way, Ernest London,
you wrote a great piece
in The New York Times about this.
But explain
what's off limits as things stand now.
Yes, most agencies encrypt highly
sensitive information,
such as SWAT team operations
and surveillance operations,
or they'll use alternate
means of communication
like cell phones or other other
other methods to communicate
these highly sensitive operations.
But for the general routine
dispatch operations,
most public safety agencies
leave that in the clear
for the public to monitor
because there is a benefit to that, to
the overall general public
understanding the day to day
operations of their public safety.
And I'm one who
believes that, you know, as
they say, sunshine is a
is a great disinfectant.
I like the public being able
to provide
some oversight role
relative to public servants.
But will you speak to some of the privacy
concerns and considerations
that I laid out
in introducing this segment?
Yeah, yeah, sure.
It's definitely a concern.
Most agencies, though, do not
broadcast names and addresses
and specific personal information over
unencrypted airwaves.
They'll typically take that to channels
that broadcast FDA does not allow.
So it'd be a lot more different,
difficult for the general public
to be able to hear that information.
So the privacy concerns are there?
Certainly. Yeah.
What level of concern
do you have about this
trend toward encryption?
Do you think that it's gone too far?
I rattled off some of the larger areas
that are already headed
in this direction.
You know,
public safety agencies
have had encryption technology
available to them for well over 40 years.
There's been a trend to do that.
But broadcast
it was also seen a trend
of some of the largest cities
in the countries
who have gone to encryption
actually make their live audio
available to the general public
to broadcast
to five cities like Chicago and Baltimore
who just recently encrypted their day
to day communications.
They provided delayed
like audio feed to broadcast
because they see the benefit
of the community
hearing the day to day
operations of their agencies.
When I read the story about this subject
and started to think about it,
I guess the greatest concern that I had
is that it might cause hesitancy
on the part of somebody who needs help
because maybe it's
an embarrassing predicament
or maybe they worry
that it will be perceived
as embarrassing.
Maybe it's mental health,
maybe it's domestic.
I don't know what it is,
but you don't want somebody
not to dial 911 who's in distress.
Your thoughts?
You know,
it's no different
than the media publicizing an event or,
you know,
covering a story about somebody.
We're providing a service
to the general public to keep them aware,
keep them up to date on
what's going on
in their local communities.
You know, at times during major events,
hundreds of thousands of people
will tune in to want to know
what's going on.
So there's a public good to
the general public
knowing what
their local public
public safety agencies
are doing on a day to day basis.
And those agencies, they they they know
that general public's listening
and they're cognizant of that.
So.
Lindsay Blanton,
thank you so much for being here.
Appreciate it. Thank you, Michael.